our next guest is known for lost the
vampire diaries and
v wars he's also the maker of a bourbon
called brothers bond
it doesn't come with eclipse so instead
here's a look at his love of high fives
from last time he was on
you're a high fiver i love it
[Applause]
[Music]
yes there you go sister
[Applause]
please welcome ian
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up everyone hi first of all love
that you're walking in with bourbon i
know i've never done that and we i'm so
sorry we can't high five
i know i know what are we gonna do i
guess we can drink
okay i love i love this i'm excited to
try it
guys thanks for thank you for coming
thanks for
i this is i haven't done this yet you
haven't no oh these are they're all
really here i mean they're really hard
but they're live
and they actually can hear us and we can
talk to them this is our other special
guest
brother's bond what a cool name there
baby yeah it's really cool so you and
people all right
it's paul and myself and we
you know this is i mean i don't know any
other
authentic thing that paul wesley and i
could be doing
um ten years in the making we were on
television for eight years i don't know
we were on the show called the vampire
diaries
yes and you always had the liquor card i
mean whatever i watched it maybe
well damon was a total lush
and he drank bourbon at seven in the
morning yeah so he's a vampire
he was a vampire yeah a lush a lush
vampire but
oh by the way my mom and my
mother-in-law
both say they love you oh and i know
they don't know you
but people just love this show oh
you know everybody i know if you watch
i'm pretty much the
identical person right here that i am in
my life
yep yep like see chris was like yep we
should all just
yeah kelly the good and the bad
it's just what it is no it's really
amazing i mean seeing
you know people be able to sort of carry
this torch through this crazy time is
really
really special and by the way a lot of
people are you know there are a lot of
companies being built
this thing we built during covid i know
a lot of things are coming out of it
like silver lining kind of thing
it is silver lining let's talk about
this um
[Laughter]
nice segue no i do want to talk about
bourbon i love bourbon why did you go
bourbon why'd you do bourbon
bourbon paul and i love bourbon yeah and
the boys bonded over bourbon on the show
on screen paul and i bonded
over bourbon off-screen paul likes to
remind me it's the only way that he
could
tolerate me um but
we had this bond over this amazing
liquid i'm from louisiana we take it
very seriously we name streets after
bourbon yeah
um but paul was from europe his family
his family's from europe he's from the
east coast
and he moved down to atlanta and all of
a sudden he's exposed to
so much of this great brown liquor
called bourbon and
we just we loved it what about brothers
bond is that just from
is it a tie-in obviously it's clearly a
nod to our characters but
also too in a time in which
and paul and i talk about this with our
team all the time which by the way most
of my team is all in texas this is like
very cheap wisely all right yeah right
but the idea is is that in a time in
which we need
unity and community more than ever
bonding in any way you can get it it's
now
yeah and that is our company ethos which
is to
encourage bonds strengthen bonds
both new and old and through that i
think
through that company ethos and through
that sort of
the idea that bonding is important
talking is important
sharing is important we're going to
really get to a great place and this is
the company that will do it and
you know i love it yeah it's really
special so i want to taste it
so listen here's what we here's what we
were chasing this is why it took us over
a year
to blend this in my living room in my
kitchen
there were measuring graduated measuring
cylinders all over the house our wives
thought we were crazy
by the way this was like two or three
four in the morning but we were chasing
what at times felt like a ghost
so this is smooth smooth but super
complex complex enough for someone who
loves bourbon smooth enough for someone
who
doesn't drink bourbon and when we give
this to people that don't drink bourbon
they go oh i didn't realize i like
bourbon
oh it's only your bourbon so yeah so my
mouth is watering just from that teaser
so the idea is it's called an equal
sensory proportion meaning you're going
to taste all the grains over your tongue
okay but kind of in harmony and balance
okay
i am all about harmony imbalance y'all
okay let's do it cheers
here we go
whoa that is smooth thank you no
joke i i don't have any work after this
[Laughter]
um well everybody you've gotta i've been
sipping on this this is so good
no joke brothers bond bourbon is
available online
and in stores and select markets across
the country starting may 1st
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever